I hope my character is sitting down let
me say that I did a cameo in season one
I was I was a guest at Danny's wedding
and the original pilot that we shot and
in that case I was I was standing up it
was in Morocco we shot it in Morocco and
I was standing up and you know if you've
ever been on a film shoot they shoot
four hours from different angles and
that angles and you know buy it by the
end it was cold and it was it was that
Morocco you know it's very hot during
the day but at night especially when we
were shooting it gets really cold so I'm
sitting there freezing and my back was
killing me buddy had the evening and I
said if I ever do another cameo I'm
going to have a nice comfortable seat so
we'll work on that other than that I
don't know it's actually I mean I hope
to do a cameo but a lot depends on the
schedule I have to get over there at the
right time and to the to the shoot and
then hopefully we can we can work in
something so there hasn't been any
decision made about well we've discussed
it but you know we haven't even got to
order for season four yet and so it's
not going to be in this season I haven't
filmed anything in this season two if
they do it it would be season four and
we have to get HBO has to order season
for first and then we'll put together
shooting schedule and then we'll see how
it measures with my schedule and you
know it would be great if it could work
out I'd really i'd really like to do it
i did i did brief cameos and a couple of
my old twilight zone episodes and beauty
and the beast so that would be cool too